and he said you won't [ __ ] shag on
bread and jam I'm Kyle Shepherd and this
is cheddar checking out cheddar
I've been rainin episode three get in
the final leg of a hidden britain tour
live bag was brought me to cheddar gorge
it's in Somerset in England and it's
named after a cheese mental well it's
not and it's where they make cheddar
cheese Josh you think you're in the back
and low and then you see it cost of
coughing like what's the cost of coffee
do and their wives would cost a coffee
though
heaven knows why the goat's liver man oh
I'm just watching their poo chatter
gorgeous massive plops in the hammy boy
would have loved smashing this hairpin
bends it was a bit hard to get an idea
of the scale of it though but fear not
lab Bible have always got a solution
I bet the men dip gliding Club assualt
chapter cores from the ground know about
seat from the sky in this thing today
Carl got the advantage of flying in the
motor glider because the best of both
worlds so we've got the independence to
be able to launch like a light aircraft
and yet when we're at height we can
switch the engine off and go through the
glide exercises and we flight just like
a glider it's quite small isn't it cozy
cozy yes a good way to put it
so might like your copilot for today
absolutely copilot Shepard let's do it
[Music]
[Music]
man this was cool I had a few nerves at
the thought of being over 2,000 feet in
the air and Steven turning the engine
off whoa that is a eyes of weird feeling
you didn't feel like we're moving
the last thing we want is onto crashes
[Music]
flying over the gorge was unreal I've
seen him done some pretty cool things on
this trip I never fought a fly plane and
without an engine I thought was pretty
hardcore actually and so Stephen told me
that there were 14 year olds who do it
all the time that was incredible
absolutely unbelievable I was flying
like like some cruising Suppan for
accepting up the missiles it's living
the dream it's living the dream no no no
no wrong song but yeah that is it well
thank you very much I'd know sometime up
in the air and Stephen is a bloody
legend I kind of seemed like a cool dad
but that wasn't me done for the day you
Oh No
and by this point lab bible knew i could
pretty much do anything so off we went
to my final challenge buzzing like a bee
flight Lord of the Rings
master master my name is Smeagol master
is the ring
compression on it
motocross I was well up for this driving
a biker on a truck would be well easy
put it this way I've flown a plane I've
driven the tank I've even written nuns
mobility scooters around the block a few
times I could this pain no it's not a
sorry for our paint spray paints a
lubricant
everything's cut oil on I got kicked out
like a pro so off I went to leave Jordan
a super cool dude who's a plenty of
awesome biker to I could tell we were
gonna be best mates Jordan Jordan Jordan
why did you do not you can fit he could
easily fit two people on their speed
Jordan we've made our wave it's a truck
and feel a little apprehensive then
definitely I can definitely ride this
bike yeah cool yeah first attempt yeah
first attempt yeah just a button this
one
[Music]
hold on
[Music]
after I've gotten used to the bike and
now the practice area Jordan said I was
ready to have a crack at the main track
and I suspected out from the class
[Music]
it's very good I've got a bit of a cold
so I just bought salim this one let's
prove for them in the wash
okay so maybe motocross wasn't crazy as
I thought would be but still I was in
desperate need of a drink and there's no
drink more west country than side our
summit will concider which is a
traditional side a farm and there's
Somerset and I'm about to meet Roger
runs the places that's going mean what
would you like to dry or medium or sweet
I don't know you better go on medium
then I'll go medium then give some you
need is right for the man yeah
geez all of us all the best Rogers been
living on and running the farm his whole
life he took over from his granddad at
21 and he still seems praying love of
cider
are you drunk side or ever since they
are four or five years of age they're
not a telling that I used to drink 16 20
points a day never been a old never been
bad so that's what secrets through a
long life lots of cyber yeah his side's
been dropped by over celebs Lily Allen
mick jagger jamie oliver all the
glastonbury at one point his proper
passionate about cheddar cheese and all
I have a big hunk you know he grease the
ropes what's the story on this no thanks
he done them in this brainer Banksy hmm
Wow Roger was a character he was larger
than life
he looks what he does and he was really
happy I mean like really really happy
lot of things will say he Apple day I
rare drink gallon the cider yo and he
said you won't [ __ ] shag on bread and
jam welcomes forum was well with its a
mud little barn full of history and
character bars and changed like a
hundred years you can lose hours in
there just exploring
that might have had something to do with
four giant barrels of cider like a lot
yeah good cider making belt yeah Cheers
so on that note it's time for me to
leave I'll split them pretty Mary what
was sad see the trip was over
I've been some amazing places and met
some dead cool people
zip wide over a canyon done poetry play
bagpipes condor mountain well sort of
driven a tank it's work some dance be
much fun a catapult buddy yeah it might
not quite be the Grand Tour being in the
UK November and all but Great Britain
has been ace much pretty good as over to
be honest he's definitely coming up
through second okay sir uh that's what I
like a little britain its quirks
Oh